EU ministers in charge of telecoms will
assess progress on a proposal aiming at
making public sector websites more
accessible and user-friendly having the
same rules in all EU countries would
help website developers offer their
products and services across the 28 EU
countries without extra costs from
having to comply with different National
rules
having more user-friendly webs would
also be to the advantage of all
especially those with disabilities or
older people
ministers are also set to discuss the
new rules regarding the EU
telecommunications markets the focus
will be twofold addressing roaming
charges as soon as possible so that
citizens can make cheaper calls while
traveling in Europe and discussing the
principles of net neutrality which
relates to the management of internet
traffic by internet service providers
ministers are also due to adopt
conclusions on internet governance this
is about Europe's role in shaping the
future of Internet governance based on a
model which is inclusive and
multi-stakeholder and underpinned by
human rights and Democratic Values
finally ministers are expected to
discuss how telecommunications can
further contribute to achieving the eu's
growth and competitiveness goals